you did something nice for me do you
know what it is uh I do what is it well
I built this home and I put in that
retaining wall which is help uh I I I
think I know what you're talking about
what does involve it involves food oh no
oh it involves you being body slammed by
a sumo wrestler uh that's right you were
there and I was so this was a I was very
concerned but I was like that is the
greatest [__] television I think I've
ever seen
if Bobby lives then it's the greatest
thing I've ever seen if he dies pretty
good way to go out that was a terrible
night wait what happened I I I was how
did you not tell her I know you've been
body slammed at the Long Beach Laugh
Factory yeah no but this was on
television oh god oh not the private one
Joe was a guest judge on there and uh
and I I I had to fight a summa wrestler
he picked me up and slammed me on my
back not on the mat though on concrete
on concrete like on a curb on a curb on
a curb there was a there was a circle
where the mat is which is hard enough
but you're you were B I don't know what
you were pile D driven driven and I when
that happened I was like oh I don't
think that Suma wrestler got any notes
on how to treat the people that are
hosting the show yeah yeah and I don't
think he showed up at the thing I think
he was just there like I know what to do
well I remember you were so brok and we
had to go get Imaging at the hospital oh
yeah that that game [__] me up that
that that show [__] me up blew your
knees out blew my knees out my bag
everything it was terrible and would you
if you got another season would you have
done it yeah they offered and I go um
I'll do it but for I do it but for a
little more money but then ABC was like
then this pandemic happened I thought it
was CBS whatever oh it was C it was CBS
for the record I got to hang out with
Venus Williams she was like my partner
and I was like I cannot I was was the
best I was Star Struck and I'm not
kidding yeah her and also um I got to
meet Landon Donovan mhm I love soccer
but here's the nice thing you did for me
I'm turning this off I thought my thank
you my ring camera went off and then
groon was on our show yes grank was also
on there gronowski um but the nice thing
you did for me it was involving food
specifically Pizza can you tell me what
it is I force fed you like a goose no no
no like foga no
did I get you a reservation at a
restaurant no but you made a suggestion
I said don't get the pineapple no a
pizza you go you got don't eat pizza you
don't need it you're not in your you're
not in your 20s you can Splurge once in
a while but intermittent fasting is
something to think about no you said you
recommended a restaurant a pizza
restaurant in not in the California oh
Arizon Chris Bianca that's it oh he's
got restaurants here now he does he does
but years ago right I ran I went you
here's what you were performing there at
the standup live right yeah and I was my
my mom lives in town so I was just there
and I go oh Joel's playing um stand up
live I'm going to go say hi you're very
nice to do that I was just bored you
were bored it could have been well you
with your
mom no I was going so I sto by you let
me hang out in your green room yeah my
green room I mean you're the headliner I
mean I guess so I was hanging out with
you and you pulled me aside and he goes
yo dude you got to go to this pizza
place yeah and I go well it's Pizza he's
like no trust me you have to go it's the
best pizza I've ever had yeah and I went
the next night and he was right I I
remember I was there with my brother and
I we were like going I think this is the
one of the best pizzas we've ever had
it's and we and we've always thought U
positively about you since then oh thank
you that was a kindhearted thing you're
number one now w made it made it sorry
Ken I knew I can get in there uh yeah
Chris Bianca they just did his uh Chef's
Table on Netflix and it's just great and
he his story is amazing and or when we
came to Phoenix he was selling
mozzarella door
too yeah yeah yeah and he worked at
Whole Foods making pizza for a while and
then he built one of the restaurants
next to that Whole Foods as like you
know an homage yeah I mean when you
actually eat good
pizza you can tell a difference I mean
you could it really kind of changes you
in a weird way and you go oh this is the
way it's supposed to be done you know do
you understand what I'm saying I
couldn't agree more yeah yeah it's like
Jin bad Jin makes no sense yeah good Jin
is so good yeah same thing with wine but
it's just like what why would we ever
put this in our B and then you oh right
yeah and then I I can eat 25 of those
pizzas and I've had pizza kind of that
looks like it well I'll be at a
restaurant go oh it looks like that
restaurant yeah and then when you eat it
you go that's not it no Cris and it's in
Downtown LA now it's great have you been
to laan Tika in Hollywood who you doing
more Francesco uh so what what is it
what's it called La antika it's l
apostrophe antika and it's a or Lano
excuse me and it's a steakhouse it is
not it is pasta and pizza it's a guy
from Sicily I've never been there